hey guys
Greg here another injustice trailer
right before the games gonna come out
just can't stop releasing footage it's
the amazing spider-man 2 all over again
alright now this one a Morgan border
it's the Joker's gameplay every Joker
was one of the best parts of the first
injustice game so that enough chitchat
alcohol a single alcohol rather I'll
know Jason Todd he's pathetic
you're contemptible and you're both look
so different
whoa whoa
ouch there's progress soon
[Music]
oh damn
ouch
a cigarette now whoa
[Music]
it's like the voice of Mark Hamill but
the look of Jared Leto's Joker
fascinating
well the gameplay does look cool to
Joker I mean what I really like about
all the Joker's moves and like how the
first one was and the new Joker look is
pretty cool I guess I'm not like I'm
painted that many means home on asserted
love it
but it still was fine I know that's not
Mark Hamill's voice it just sounds like
the Mark Hamill voice with the look of
Jared Leto from Suicide Squad I'm really
curious as to how people are going to
respond to this Joker he's still going
to have the personality the movements
are cool and the story doesn't seem like
it's centered around the Joker as much
as the first injustice game had a more
central point for the choker but man
they really they really did give us some
more emo looking Joker this time around
it actually kind of reminds you Tobey
Maguire spider-man 3 but the gameplay I
think I think the moves are really cool
because you know the Joker is not really
known for fighting so whenever they have
Joker doing stuff in the gameplay when
he's actually fighting people it's done
very Joker s clap the especially blow up
a wrench hit the gun that has the bane
fly come out of it but then actually
fire something I love the I don't know
the x-ray fatality move he puts them in
the chairs and put the dynamite
underneath them shocks them they blow
all that so that's that's some really
funny [ __ ] just every every part of his
movements he moves like the Clown Prince
he jumps I thought that was really funny
every one of his movements it's like
okay this isn't this isn't losing the
essence of the Joker this is how the
Joker would probably fight if he knew
how to really fly and I really am liking
the gameplay footage the way they've
enhanced all the levels and I love all
the [ __ ] where they throw them into the
background yeah I never yeah I never see
that coming all looks aside I'm just
glad he's in the game that's this is
what I really give a [ __ ] about yes it's
not Mark Hamill's voice it's more email
looking Joker but the gameplay still
looks cool the Joker character still
seems like the Joker that's all that
really counts to me in this one and the
part of me is wondering did they change
up his design for this specific story is
is like the way he looks have something
specifically to do with where this
injustice game is actually taking place
who knows you got to find out in a
couple weeks when I play the actual game
and yes I know I've done a lot of game
trailer reactions where I don't actually
play the game but there's one I'm
definitely playing I like I really like
the first one my best friend Tony Gill
he has a pre-order we're gonna play it
day what he has a twitch account so I'll
let you know if we're gonna do a
livestream story mode version of that
keep a lookout anyway subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow us at the
real rejects and may have the greg alba
on the insta and the twit and we really
want the patreon got a lot of beautiful
friends over there supporting the
channel getting their rewards and after
this weekend probably around Sunday
we're going to start releasing more than
just Bob because we released like behind
the scenes or deleted moments from
videos on there alright now however
we're actually going to start putting
you know exclusive full-length videos on
the patreon as well so go check out ok
so calm